make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and
yeah let's begin
happy new year everybody hopefully you
guys had a really good new year's eve
you were responsible you didn't do
anything crazy but managed to find some
way to be happy in the midst of all this
chaos and madness but we are picking up
with tales from the dark multiverse dark
knight's metal now this is the original
dark knights medal right so not what's
going on right now with dark knight's
death metal this is
the original metal event that's taking
place and here's an important thing to
understand this is a this is a cool
concept
tales from the dark multiverse as we
know has always been designed to
highlight
essentially like worlds in the dark
multiverse right it's like a series of
what-if stories from you know each of
these individual universes right these
individual worlds and how things played
out on those worlds so something that i
do want to clear up here with regards to
a little bit of confusion
these are not really what ifs right it's
not like what if
in the dark multiverse where batman
became an evil version of the flash that
he instead became like an evil version
of green arrow or something like that
that's not really what it is right it's
just in the dark multiverse there is
this world
where things happen right that's that's
basically how this this whole thing
plays out and that's why this particular
story
is actually designed to answer the
question why haven't we really seen
anything regarding the dark multiverse
in dc comics right why is it that since
darth knight a dark knights medal
started we haven't really seen anybody
reference the dark multiverse or travel
there or anything along those lines
right what's going on
in that place and so this gives us the
answer right now an important
distinction to understand here
is that initially when we saw the
original dark knights metal event that
at the end of that story we saw the
superheroes donning
what was in effect you know metal x more
or less right kind of like this metal
that was used that could defeat barbados
and it worked right it basically ended
up taking him out right end up pushing
the dark multiverse back to where it was
supposed to be and the positive
multiverse you know lived happily ever
after until like the next event the next
crisis
what this question answers is in this
situation
that there is a world out there where
the events of dark knight's metal took
place and what it led to
was the whole idea of this metal x
effectively being a trap that instead of
it being a kind of metal that could be
used by the superheroes to defeat
barbados instead what ended up happening
is it was a trap
set by barbados and what he did is that
as soon as the armor was donned by
batman it basically allowed barbados to
overtake these guys right to immediately
subjugate and overtake these guys batman
superman wonder woman and green lantern
hal jordan
and then turn them into giant dragons
right it was basically the last step
here
and that once that was done once batman
was basically taken over by barbados it
in turn
allowed him to completely enter reality
to move away from the realm he was in
and to totally take over everything now
this is where things get kind of hairy
and a little wild because this is where
the dark multiverse starts to
deteriorate
as soon as this actual process of
conquering happens
then in turn it leads to what's called
the death wave and the death wave has
kind of given us
given to us in a couple different forms
right this idea that like maybe it's
just the influence of barbados as he
travels from one world to the next and
like wipes out all life on those worlds
but the truth is that the dark that the
death wave is literally the death of the
dark multiverse so it's like if you guys
remember the incursions from hickman's
avengers and new avengers imagine that
except the dark multiverse right like
literally whole realities are being
destroyed it's basically what it is here
and so that's why for the most part at
least once we get to the end of this
we'll see there's there's a pretty
significant concept that dc introduces
here right but there is one
individual who's trying to do what he
can to save what other worlds are left
right and he's jumping from like
from like earth 3 in the dark multiverse
like the crime syndicate
to fawcett city on earth s or maybe it's
earth 5. it used to be earth s back
before the events of crisis on defenders
um but you've got neo-gotham so
essentially you know batman beyond in
the dark multiverse like it's kind of
funny because a lot of these characters
that we just haven't really seen before
that we do want to see right like i want
to see
a dark multiverse version of batman
beyond like i want to see that right
what
like give me a dark a multiverse version
of like terry mcginnis right i want to
see that guy i think it'd be amazing but
each one of these worlds that he's
running through
are worlds that are basically being
eradicated right they're being destroyed
and the universes themselves are dying
because of the death wave
and ultimately this guy ends up
traveling back to the main dc
universe or at least to the the main dc
mark dark multiverse world right because
this whole story takes place in the dark
multiverse he ends up traveling back to
dark multiverse prime we can call it
dark universe prime and ultimately we
end up finding out this guy
is the dark multiverse version of signal
here's an important thing that i want to
explain here right because this first
little tidbit may have thrown you off
with regards to like other worlds and
things like that so the idea is
is that you know in order to think about
this effectively think about the
positive multiverse as an upside down
pyramid that you've got the point the
very top point at the bottom and then
you've got the wide side at the very end
now imagine that like below that you
have an upside down triangle
now the point the very sharp tip there
is basically the positive matter
multiverse uh
earth zero is what it is when you have
earth zero in the negative multiverse or
the dark multiverse that very top point
that's earth zero right that's how that
works just kind of give you guys
perspective so
it's the opposite the the direct
opposite of the main dc universe right
that's that's kind of what earth
negative zero
is well it doesn't i don't know if you
can really have negative zero but you
guys understand right
that's kind of what that is right and so
the results of this is that what we end
up finding out here is that of course
duke thomas as we know
has the power to see into the past and
as soon as he arrives back here he's
immediately set upon by barbados and the
forces of the dragons right like you
know wonder woman and superman and uh
and green
green lantern hal jordan and aquaman now
one thing to understand here this is not
true foreign barbados that's not his
actual form that's just how he looks or
at least when he took control of batman
and batman operating as a servant of
barbados for barbados himself we haven't
we don't really see his true form here
right i mean you kind of do
he's almost kind of ethereal to a degree
right he's almost like this god-like
entity that exists out there
uh more of a concept than anything else
at this point because what it looks like
has happened over the course of the dark
multiverse is that barbados has kind of
channeled himself one directly into
bruce wayne on earth zero
really kind of is a a prime thing right
saying like you know i rule this area
but two his influence is spread out
throughout the rest of the dark
multiverse as well so seemingly he split
himself into portions it's kind of what
it what it looks like we're not
directly told that it's kind of one of
the issues you run into there's a lot
that's just not really explained here
but you know for his part where he tries
to go against these these dragons
he's overcome pretty fast right i mean
he's dawning this this monitor armor
right so it's multiversal armor
basically armor of gods and it is really
powerful but there really isn't a whole
lot he can do against these guys because
he doesn't know how to really wield the
armor the way that he's supposed to
and so because of that what you end up
having is uh superman you know this dark
multiverse superman that initially
intends to
to consume him and then in the process
he actually ends up breaking off one of
his teeth
and is ultimately saved by dick grayson
that dick grayson on earth zero in the
dark multiverse is still alive but he's
only one of a ragtag group of people who
basically have now what he has here is
what's called the parallax
which i think is cool it's basically
like a rock metal like a hard rock
guitar axe it looks cool it looks
amazing but it's also
infused with the remaining power rings
from the other lanterns who were there
but the reason why this matters is
because
using the axe what it does is it allows
itself to modify based on vibrational
frequencies right so
using this ax dick grayson could
potentially leave this universe but for
what it does it allows them to kind of
temporarily overcome
these dragons sort of push them back
knock them out for a couple minutes buy
them some time and basically allow them
to get out of there now one of the
things we also learn here is that
there's no love lost between duke thomas
and uh and nightwing and the reason why
is because when the invasion initially
happened when barbados and his forces
initially showed up here that what you
ended up having was duke thomas who
stole the monitor armor and then took
off into the multiverse trying to find a
way to save what other worlds were out
there and so in the eyes of dick grayson
he abandoned them in their time of need
right and so there's not really a lot of
hey man you know it's good to see you
it's him just being like do what you
always do
like you know duke just just run right
it's the only thing that you're really
good at right and so
because that what ends up happening is
that dick grayson ends up traveling back
to his base of operations he ends up
going through all these crazy things too
something called the plastic force which
is basically plastic man
just kind of spread all over the place
right you've got uh you've got like the
oblivion bar right so where you end up
having like you know john constantine
and all those guys drinking and
and that sort of stuff uh but he ends up
following him back to his main base of
operations which is the justice league
watchtower which of course has since
crashed into earth and is basically
where him and like kendra uh basically
you know hot girl where they all
basically exist right they just kind of
live there and
try to ride out their days as best they
can and just sort of survive
hawkman in his giant hawk form is is
basically here right he's in this
location uh but things are kind of wild
because
as this goes on and as they go and talk
to bobo the the talking monkey or you
know detective chimp basically uh he's
got the red tornado armor so red tornado
was kind of like vision before vision i
think but the the whole point is like
you brought somebody back right somebody
followed you and that's when they
realize that duke thomas is there now
when they realize he's there he's
immediately set upon by the flash now
this is
kind of an interesting depiction of
barry allen or at least we assume it's
barry allen we're not really giving an
explanation whether it's barry or wally
but uh he's kind of like in this this
robotic you know skeletal
form we don't really know how this guy
functions the way that he does
we're not really given any information
on him he's just kind of there and he's
basically a speedster
and that is essentially it but duke
thomas actually pitches this idea
that they can win now here's why do
thomas is so important in this story as
one of the things that dc
never really explored in the main dc
universe which i never really understood
why like it was literally scott snyder
who set dc comics up for like hey let's
explore signal and then they never did
right he just kind of fell to the
wayside became a secondary or a tertiary
character and that was it
right it was just there was nothing else
with him besides that but one of the
things that made duke so significant was
the fact that he had almost this endless
supply of hope
he always believed that things could get
better the irony behind all this
is that that used to be nightwing right
nightwing was always considered the best
of all the heroes on earth because he
was the guy who always saw good in
people no matter how bad they got no
matter how twisted things were he always
managed to find a way to see the good in
things right duke thomas doesn't really
i mean
he has that element but it's really kind
of being shined on more here
because of the fact that nightwing lost
it right that nightwing doesn't have it
anymore you know he basically seems to
have lost faith
in the ability for the world to become
better or to like save the world from
barbados destroy the dragons or anything
like that but as duke kind of pitches
this and in the face of all this hope
that he has
that when you had barbados who basically
conquered the dark multiverse and
actually intended to go after the source
that now it's like okay maybe he does
have to have it have a have a point here
right i mean the death wave is already
is already on its way even if we defeat
barbados we're not gonna be able to stop
it right so like the universe is going
to end
anyway there's nothing we can do about
it so if we are going to die
then why why go out as scavengers right
people just trying to live from one day
to the next and trying to survive why
not go out with a bang right like why
not just go out and just destroy
whatever forces of barbados that we can
now here's the thing that dick grayson
points out he tells he basically tells
duke if we're going to do that if we're
going to kill dragons
we need dragons of our own now switch
over to the batman who laughs now i know
i know i know we're all exhausted and
tired of the batman who laughs he was
probably one of the coolest characters
that dc screwed up right it was just
overexposure
like everything was the batman who lasts
he's a perfect example of what happens
when a
comic book publisher comes across a
really cool idea and then just hammers
it into the ground right just totally
destroys any interest or desire that
people have and seeing any more of the
character the cool thing about this is
we get him for like a moment right he's
not it's not some great big huge drawn
out thing
it's really more him being here as like
a plot device because he's got one of
the joker dragons under his control now
for the most part he just kind of looks
at it and considers it to be nonsensical
it's like you're not funny
you're not really interesting you're
supposed to be great and interesting but
you're not and then it basically has
been giving him a hard time all this
time right just ridiculing this dragon
all this time now he does end up picking
up on the fact that the superheroes are
on their way there right they're like
dick grayson
signal all those guys are on their way
there he basically takes the hand of
zatanna which she uses as a trophy and
then uses her magic to essentially force
them down right to bring him crashing
down and then ultimately ends up trying
to subdue all of them right like trying
to take them all over and for the most
part it's all just a ruse and a
distraction that where you end up having
him subduing barry allen or whichever
version of the flash it is where he
takes out like
you know beppo the super monkey where he
ends up taking out uh detective chimp
you know where he's got
uh hot girl and and so on that this is
all designed to be a kind of ruse where
it allows nightwing to basically sneak
in
and then cut the chains around the
dragon which in turn incinerates the
batman who laughs
this is how you do batman who laughs in
a story not in so far as killing him but
having him there for a moment or two and
then he goes on and does his own thing
right like that's that's
that's the way that you do the batman
who last you don't make 10 stories
over the course of a single year revolve
around that one character that's how you
kill
interest in your character but the
important thing is that this dragon
really kind of has a personality of its
own and it's something that we never
really knew that he had the way you end
up having his new thomas walking up to
this guy and saying look here's what's
gonna happen you got three choices
one you can kill me and then they'll all
kill you two
you know you can fly away and then
barbados will kill you anyway because
you killed the batman who laughed you
killed one of his enemies or three
you can join us and there's a high
likelihood we'll die but at least we can
destroy some of his forces in the
process
and and ultimately like joker dragon is
like deal so like literally they all end
up boarding the dragon
they jump on this dragon and go flying
into these forces of barbados right go
flying in against these guys now
they're all each prepared for each one
of these battles right so you've got
the flash who goes flying in who goes
just literally running on top of the
dragon building up some momentum goes
running in
into the hal jordan dragon and then
snatches the ring off of his hand right
like literally snatches his hand out
which basically destroys both the flash
but it also kills the dragon form in the
process now it is one of these things
where like the essence of his character
still lives there so presumably the soul
of how jordan i guess still resides
inside his ring
enough that the flash can kind of
communicate with him to a degree and
basically help him move on to the
afterlife so to speak so i guess you can
largely say this version of the flash is
like the black racer right you could you
could very well
make that connection here but the
takeaway from this is that the flash
dies right the flash is the first one to
fall
following that you've got uh detective
chimp and then you also end up having a
hawkgirl and hawkman who essentially
fall now detective chimp does an
interesting way where he basically
lassos the wonder woman dragon and says
like you know it's time for you to face
what it is that you've become now
because she is a medusa it also ends up
you know infecting detective chimp he
turns to stone alongside a suit and of
course he's destroyed that way but so is
wonder woman she's destroyed by being
forced to you know be exposed to
to her own little tendrils snakeheads
that kind of thing and now for
uh for aquaman who's like this giant
aquaman dragon he it looks like it's
just kind of like something akin to
self-detonation right is more or less
what it looks like but the longer short
is that each one of these guys dies so
that the only ones really left alive
are the superman dragon and then
nightwing and signal and so with
nightwing really pulling the strings
here
what you have here is like superman you
know using his heat vision right to try
to take out nightwing as best
he can it doesn't really work and while
he is talking a little bit of snack a
little bit a little bit of smack he's
like you know you were basically always
a poor man's batman anyway that kind of
a thing then actually what he ends up
doing is drawing out this kryptonite
pick and he actually got this
from when they first encountered the
batman who laughed here a few minutes
ago right that that nightwing it kind of
snuck along
the different trophies that the batman
who laughs had and then located a piece
like a little shard of green kryptonite
and then used that shot of green
kryptonite to destroy this version of
superman it's a genius idea
it's a really cool idea of course he
uses the parallax to do it right i mean
i really hope that dc sells this in some
form because i would buy it somebody's
gonna make a version of it on etsy or
something like that but like i would buy
it but the funny thing is that superman
is still in there
and ultimately he ends up thanking dick
grayson for the fact that he basically
kills him and spares him his this
existence which really is a fate worse
than death and so the last person
standing here right the last one
standing here
is basically uh signal and barbados
right like sigil and barbados these two
just going toe-to-toe now as they fight
is it is an interesting thing because
now it does kind of lend credence to the
idea that it really is just
barbados right but we'll actually find
out there's a little more to it than
that but the
the the big takeaway is that using his
ability to jump
from location to location based on the
uh on the the monitor arm or the monitor
suit that what he actually ends up doing
is teleporting inside of this giant bat
dragon
locating bruce wayne and when he locates
bruce wayne he basically removes him
from uh from being being harnessed being
tied up inside of barbados which is how
he's using him as a as you know using
him as a giant dragon and then once
that's done
he kills bruce wayne right now killing
bruce wayne is significant here and the
reason why is because if you guys
remember the original dark knights metal
event bruce wayne himself was a vessel
for barbados right as long as bruce
wayne was alive the barbados could
use him to enter into the positive
multiverse to effectively possess him
and that's what happened here right that
element still remains the same that
barbados actually successfully managed
to possess batman
and then in turn used him as a means to
conquer the rest of the dark multiverse
and so because of that
once this version of batman is dead
barbados is just kind of
you know seemingly his essence is
non-existent anymore again we're not
given a definitive explanation here i
mean it basically does look like
barbados is
essentially dead but if barbados existed
with inside the dark multiverse and then
he possessed bruce wayne and then
ultimately bruce wayne was killed
wouldn't that lend credence to the idea
that barbados essence would still be
alive the answer to that question comes
in the form of the fact that once uh
once
one signal basically uses the parallax
to cut through the uh the body of
barbados and then fashion a suit out of
it that two things take place
the first is he becomes what's called
the dark knight right this is basically
a version of batman who can travel from
universe to universe and is also
in possession of monitor technology
monitor armor
and a really kind of a new form of armor
created out of barbados which makes them
insanely powerful right this is
basically a god to your batman the
second thing that happens is that
because the entirety of the dark
multiverse's existence
is the result of all the worst
nightmares and the worst possibilities
of everybody in the positive multiverse
the dark multiverse will effectively be
reborn you know it's as soon as it's
destroyed with the death wave kind of
spilling over and wiping everything out
that as people begin to dream up and and
to have fears
based on terrible versions of themselves
you know superheroes super villains
things like that the dark multiverse
will start to take form again
that what signal does is he enters into
kind of like this void right what's left
of the dark multiverse this kind of big
empty vast
space and then he ends up meeting
tempest fujinon right this guy
who's basically the watcher of the dark
multiverse the one that we kind of
follow will
follow around and he shows us these
various events and different things like
that and duke's like so wait a minute
let me understand this all these worlds
were dying
all these terrible things were happening
and you were just watching so he just
punches the crap out of tempest fudging
on
and then goes forward as the final
knight right this guy who intends to
essentially travel through the dark
multiverse and destroy all these really
dark versions right these really twisted
characters that will pop up
as time goes on now the big take away
from this and the reason why i love this
story and the reason why it's so cool
is because what it does is it gives dc
the ability to write a series of stories
based around this final night that
travels from universe to universe world
to world
facing off against dark multiverse
versions of heroes that we know from the
main dc universe it basically leaves it
open-ended you could launch an entire
publishing initiative based on this just
a single line of comics out there and
all it does is explore duke thomas
and all the terrible possibilities that
exist in the in the dark multiverse it's
a great idea
whether or not it's an idea that'll
that'll come to fruition or even be done
well
is something only time will tell but i'm
excited about it right i think
i think it's a really really cool
concept so with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
if you are new here to comments explain
make sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and i will
catch you all later
[Music]
peace
[Music]
[Music]
you